عندك في هذه الجهه المقابله ما هي اخر
المعلومات
نعم دعينا نشير الى ان ما يجري ربما في
عرض البحر والحديث عن تحركات للبحريه
الاسرائيليه يبدو ان الهدف من ذلك عاده ما
يكون محاولات لاحباط عمليات للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه من جهه البحر سواء كان ذلك
عمليات تسلل لوحدات الكوماندوز البحري
التابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه كما حصل في
مواجهات سابقه عندما تمكن عناصر من
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ومن الكوماندوز
البحري من تجاوز الحدود والوصول الى شاطئ
ذكين والاشتباك مع القوات الاسرائيليه
هناك ربما يكون هذا
من جانب القطع البحريه الاسرائيليه محاوله
لرصد تحركات معينه للمقاومه من جهه البحر
او محاوله ايضا لاحباط عمليات
تفجير قد تنطلق من جانب من جهه السلع
الساحل لقطاعي غزه ذلك ان ايضا المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اثبتت ان لديها قدرات بحريه
وغواصات مفخخه كانت تستعد لتفعيبها في
جوله المواجهه في عام 2021 وكانت البحريه
الاسرائيليه قد رصدتها
ووجهت ضربات لها في ذلك الحين